[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is Emmy Tony and Grammy
award-winning actor singer writer and
director his film anything is possible
is streaming now on Prime video Let's
see a clip
you're so nice
yes you are Irma last year Joey Zhang
made a ceramic soccer ball and put in
the Kiln after he left he grabbed it
built a hole in it so it wouldn't
explode with the heat yeah well maybe I
was trying to protect my Egyptian fan
spot from the detronus you were already
glazing your HSN fan spot Joey was the
only one still sculpting it's always my
friend nah you're perpetually a nice
there's nothing wrong with that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh my God that's so funny
hi everybody
[Applause]
oh my God you're so funny I can't stand
it I'm so glad you're here that I can
tell you how I feel how do you feel
sweetheart Billy Porter you are here
because you are a Broadway Legend you
have elevated
you've elevated every cast you've ever
been a part of whether you're writing or
singing or acting you've never left a
single crumb you made a choice to live
in your truth and it has sparked actual
change there are a whole lot of people
who are more themselves than they could
have ever thought they could be because
of you I love you welcome
okay that is really sweet and I will
receive it thank you oh cheers honey
cheers darling I didn't what are you
drinking spicy margarita
[Music]
is it so so spicy can you take spicy
stuff oh yeah can you do you think you
could enter a hot pepper eating cup no
no no no no no no what's your I'm not
spicy like that what's the spiciest
thing you can eat it's not like that
it's not the spicy like that I just like
a little kick you know you get chicken
tikka masala uh-huh do you get one
little Chili Pepper two or three okay so
you know you've you've outdone me I know
but it goes to like five or six what
yeah you can get that yes and so I'll do
three I'm medium okay well you asked me
you're spicy
I'm the spicy one
spicy what hey tell me about anything is
possible
so it is a wonderful Coming of Age
romantic comedy
in the spirit of the old uh John Hughes
movies and and it follows well I I say
the spirit of the old John Hughes movies
and with a cast that looks like the
world today so it follows a um
black Trans girl in high school in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania and she falls in
love uh or she gets a Muslim boyfriend
and it's like you know it looks like the
things we've seen before but like
you know it's a little different you
know and it's really sweet and it's a
celebration of transness a celebration
of authenticity and
you know I hope it helps to um normalize
something that
um has been politicized and turned into
like
you know fear-mongering
um it's a really beautiful film so I'm I
I feel very blessed to be a part of it
it is beautiful it's a beautiful thing
it's beautiful and it's perfect and
you're beautiful and you're perfect I
was recently at Global Citizens Festival
and I was there when you sang your hit
songs stranger things well it's not a
hit yet but hopefully you all will make
it a hit
because it's coming out as a single as a
result of that performance it's coming
out as a single ahead of the election
because I really fancy myself a
political activist kind of artist and so
my music represents that
and you know the song really speaks the
lyric really speaks to this idea that we
have no time to be afraid we have no
time to be terrified we have to stand up
and speak up and go and vote and demand
our respect for our humanities and so
it's a song that speaks to that and I'm
really excited about it you know the the
single's coming out and I'm going full
hog well that makes me want to hear a
little bit of it can we show a clip I
can't do nothing
[Music]
forever
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it was a beautiful performance I loved
it I was watching it from the other
stage
um it was very good thank you um I bet
you've heard this before you're a crazy
talented performer and I'll never get
enough now you
you won't just have a seat for one
second
unprotected yes everyone absolutely
adores it now it's coming out in
paperbacks it's coming out in paperback
on October 25th and I'm finally going to
be able to go on a book tour because it
came out during covid and I wasn't able
to like
go out on the road and promote it in the
way that I would have loved to so I'm
coming to a town near you where's the
camera
dude yeah you man
um are you emotionally prepared for some
rapid fire questions
yes
time for a small slumber party so what
is your favorite part you have ever
played
I'm doing at the moment
um
so I would say I'm not doing a role at
the moment but the last role I did
I was pray tell
um
impose and you know that was
life-changing
for me and I I really am very proud of
that work it was unbelievable I think
poses one of my favorite shows of all
time it made me feel yeah
it made me feel so smart because I got
to know all of this and then so dumb
because I didn't it was great so good I
love though expanding what I know and
getting a taste of a different culture
yeah and that's what art does that's
what art has the power to do and I love
that because that's the intention
next rapid fire question dog or cat dog
that's the only right answer what is
your dream
Broadway role
it's one night only it doesn't have to
be crazy this is your dream you're gonna
blow it out you know it's really
interesting these questions are
interesting because when your dreams
come true you got to get new ones right
my dreams
I played Lola in Kinky Boots I created
an iconic character in a Broadway show
like it doesn't get any better than that
so I don't really know and I'm just you
know living my life and allowing the
universe to tell me what you know what
is it gonna be there are no limits yeah
you know what is it gonna be what is
next I don't I really don't know I act
like that too yeah I like to leave it
open and say I I personally I couldn't
have dreamed this big so I'm just gonna
just let that's my thing yeah that's my
thing I never imagined that my dreams
would come true because of my
authenticity because of my queerness you
know I was told my queerness would be my
liability for decades and it was until
it wasn't and now you know my queerness
is my superpower in a way you know and
so
I never dreamed about that I was trying
to be straight enough so I could eat
I didn't know that say that for a long
time you know stilettos are platforms
well
that's tricky I will say platforms
because the pitch
allows for one
to walk in them for hours you get the
heights without the pain you get the
hype without the pain honey yes
my metatarsals are a little bit older
now
next question what we got to do to get
you to ask her I have some stuff in the
work
I mean I'm trying you know I have a team
who's trying you know I have to say this
though yes it's great it's fun I'm
excited to be one of water away from
egot and
as an artist
it's not the reason why I do the work
and
I like it
I'ma say both right it's like I'm not
one of those artists that's like oh no I
don't care no I do care
and I bought one oh wait um
in God's time not mine yeah
this is a question I like to ask
everybody
you're in Dreamgirls you have to pick
which which dream girl you're going to
be is it Laurel is it Effie or is it
Dina
you have to pick one which one I'm gonna
kill you
[Laughter]
oh my God like the biggest Dream Girls
freak I am the reason why I'm in this
business is because of seeing you know
Dream Girls on the Tony Awards
um
you know I would say
it used to be Effie
but now I don't want to work that hard
so now it's Dana
[Applause]
and I'm snatched now you know so now you
know on Snapchat I can play Dina instead
of light
and be glamorous if you're the most
glamorous person I've ever met I love
you so bad I'm so glad you exist my
world is better for it Billy Porter
everybody
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]